why should you be able to get any
contracts to the United States
government if you're going to advise
foreign Nations who are hostile to us
and make gobs of money off of them why
should you be getting US Government
contracts what is going on here with
Ukraine and I would disconnect that very
obviously from all of the lies that
Rashida Talib and AOC just said about
Israel Israel has an enemy on its border
they're not asking for troops or
anything else they're asking for
Military Support so they can stop a
genocidal organization from killing them
and by the way they still have American
hostages which nobody talks about it's
as opposed to Ukraine where it's very
unclear what the goals are we just keep
pouring more and more money and you
might go well what's that all about
check out this headline and you might
kind of figure it out BlackRock JP
Morgan and McKenzie working on Ukraine
reconstruction bank so they are going to
put together a giant Bank you understand
these these giant conglomerates that own
all of these assets and everything else
and I'm not even saying everything about
them is evil I'm just trying to show you
what is going on here the more that you
UK the more that Ukraine gets demolished
and destroyed the more that these
companies will come in for the
Reconstruction and somehow they will
make a whole bunch of cash let's go back
to Congress one more time uh because
there was another hearing yesterday uh
and this is Josh
Holly pressing Global managing partner
of McKenzie and company over why they
and they're sort of like Black Rock and
these other companies why do they do
business with America's enemies like is
that good for America if we have these
giant corporations that do business with
say China and these other countries that
are undermining American values that
doesn't seem great does it my question
is why should you be able to get any
contracts to the United States
government if you're going to advise
foreign Nations who are hostile to us
and make gobs of money off of them why
should you be getting US Government
contracts Senator we've never worked
with the Chinese Communist Party or the
central government in China to the best
of my knowledge you're working with
state-owned Enterprises this is this is
China is not a democracy they own these
companies these companies are doing the
bidding of the Chinese military and
you're making money off of it hand over
fist my question is I guess if you want
to do that I I guess it doesn't violate
the law but I just wonder why is it that
you should then be able to turn around
and make 850 million dollar in one year
loone off the American taxpayer I mean
explain that to me Senator um our work
with the federal government uh we stand
behind uh we bring well I'm sure you do
it's incredibly lucrative that's the
problem you make gobs of money off of
our enemies and then you turn around you
make gobs of money off of us it's
outrageous frankly you know I know a lot
of the Congressional stuff that we show
you it's a dog and pony show like not
much of it happens right we can expose
things but not much happens after but
that's a particularly good moment
because H's right when the when the
McKenzie guy they get government
contracts right so they get government
contracts from the United States so you
as a taxpayer you pay for these
government contracts for Mackenzie to do
their reconstruction of Ukraine and all
these other things and then and then at
the same time they work with other
countries like China although he says
we've never worked with the Communist
party but as Holly points out the
Communist party they own all of the the
Assets in China all of these companies
that you're working with they own them
so they're taken from both and as again
as Holly points out it's like yeah maybe
you can get away with it but what do we
stand for in America or are we just a
shell
company